thinking about your version versus mine
is so great cuz it's it's what you said
and that's what you okay but not you
felt like you needed a gang at that
moment I need yo I'm going to join just
to have and beat this girl's ass my
mom's [__] crazy what did you would
you what would you call it what was the
gang you called n what that's how I felt
like I need a crew I need a crew of long
socks [__] to help me fight my
mom
um so yeah we blame cartoons for
everything in the world basically Bugs
Bunny created the Crips okay he did I
can I really think it's blood's bunny
more like shut the [__] up God Marty oh
that was so
awesome now I'm over here trying to
think of other
characters
G no no more